this is the first of a new generation of
solar fairies the form style shipyard in
northern Germany developed and built it
in just six months the vessel is nearly
20 metres in length it's powered by an
emissions free electric motor the ferry
also has very low personnel demands
thanks to many technological advances
such as this magnetic docking system for
instance my single person can handle the
boat thanks to the magnetic docking
device but before it's allowed to carry
passengers the ferry has to undergo a
battery of tests one test determines
whether the ship's motors perform at
full capacity with some 40 passengers on
board the weight of the passengers is
simulated by these heavy cartons the
electric motors are able to reach a top
speed of 12 km/h the Angela fighter we
have clearly taken a step forward and I
think this new product has opened up a
market for us here in Germany as well as
abroad do you not buy yesterday
according to the company the vessel
costs less than 10 euros per hour to
operate form stars CEO is sure that that
will be a convincing argument for
potential buyers both domestic and
foreign of course we're already fielding
initial inquiries people want
information but it's too early to tell
whether or not that will materialize
into actual sales on sales and Germany
are picking up the solar fairies are
already in use on Berlin's Lakes the
shipping company expects their new ships
to ferry some 1 million passengers
across the Capitals waterways using
power from the Sun
you